[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my Luke Cage season 2 review video
I'll try to do this in his non-spoilery
away as possible there'll be some more
specific videos too for like the really
big stuff because if you haven't seen
any of the Luke Cage trailer videos that
I've done yes
iron fist does show up during Luke Cage
season 2 they do get into Heroes for
Hire think of their take on it as
Marvel's lethal weapon but it's still
largely meant to be Luke Cage season 2
following him his story in developing
the characters of Haarlem probably the
best way to talk about it would be to
talk about the Godfather you can call it
Marvel's Godfather and that would be a
very apt description of the themes of
Luke Cage season 2 so overall they did a
really good job of fixing some of the
biggest problems of Luke Cage season 1
and fixing some Iron Fist problems maybe
not completely but definitely went a
long way towards redeeming that
character so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos we're just
getting started Comic Con is coming up
there's gonna be a lot of stuff dropping
the music was off the chain the music is
always one of the best things about Luke
Cage he definitely has the best
soundtrack of all the Marvel Netflix
heroes probably any of the other
live-action TV series too but they find
funny ways of working in very specific
track references in meta ways to comment
on the actions of scenes really good
example is it early on there's the track
about night nurse playing while he's
having sex with night nurse so in the
way that they just have really badass
music that sounds awesome
there's this level of thought that goes
into it where the music itself is
commenting on the action of whatever the
scene is there's so many notable hip-hop
tracks they use I imagine their music
budget is probably as big as their
special effects budget speaking of
special effects of course lots of
upgrades to all the characters the
villains get upgrades Luke Cage gets an
upgrade he's been through defenders so
arguably he's better at using his powers
but they also have some small retcons
that make him legitimately more powerful
because of stuff that happened during
season 1 so without completely changing
how his powers work they do make him
more powerful this sort of gets into the
way they use him with the villain
character and how his powers interact
with bushmen
stirrers powers so one of the things
that they fixed from season one was
their big villain problem because you
have cottonmouth really amazing
character but he's gone halfway through
the season then you have Diamondback and
that's sort of where the series went off
the rails so they definitely picks that
Bushmaster is the big villain but a lot
of the characters exist in shades of
grey so I wouldn't call Bushmaster the
only villain he just meant to be the
villain that Luke Cage spends most of
his time fighting through the series it
wouldn't be a Marvel series if there
wasn't some sort of emotional villain
like there are other characters that
give him a lot of problems that he can't
punch which is another big change to the
character they deal a lot more with the
chip as they call it on Luke cages
shoulder like there's a moment where
Claire temple compares him to daredevil
because daredevil has this sort of
addiction to being a vigilante like he
sort of gets off on it a little bit
there's a certain thrill that he's
addicted to Luke Cage has that same
problem it gets him into trouble more
often than not like if you've seen the
trailers you seen Bushmaster basically
walks in and beats his ass because Luke
Cage gets overconfident like I said they
even big power upgrades so he's riding
high and bushmaster just completely
walks over him they do some really
interesting things with the way
bushmasters powers works to this sort of
rope in some deep cuts from the Luke
Cage Power Man comics they sort of try
to give him a kill monger Michael B
Jordan type story where he has a reason
for really hating the characters inside
Harlem and I feel like it mostly works
for the first couple of episodes after
he debuted I did have to turn subtitles
on until I could catch his Jamaican
slide it took me a while to pick it up
because he does have a very particular
dialect but they do have an interesting
twist on the idea of magic mysticism and
metahumans in a more real-world way
everybody seen Doctor Strange we know
magic exists but they find a way to make
it a little more real-world through the
nightshade character from the comics
they have an interesting twist on her
backstory too but the way bushmaster
gets his powers is very different from
the comics in the comics he's mostly
just another version of Luke Cage he
goes through the same treatment that
Luke did getting dipped in that special
bath in this sort of faux Captain
America super soldier program so I
didn't mind any of that stuff it totally
worked with his backstory and sort of
sets up for the future so
spoilers about the ending but I feel
like they try to do a good job of
leaving all the characters that do
survive to the end in good places if
they want to bring them back in future
seasons they did an amazing job with the
Moriah character alfre woodard just
completely owns the entire season even
though it's technically supposed to be
luke cage's TV show it's as much her
show as it is his I don't want to get
into too many spoilers about the
character relationships there a couple
revelations about people that are
related to some of the main characters
but they have some interesting twists
with the nightshade character and Reggie
kathy's character who's tied to the Luke
Cage character so like I said not all
the villains are villains that you punch
in the face some of them are more
emotional villains you've probably all
seen misty Nights bionic arm yes they do
the bionic arm from the comics instead
of being made by stark tech it's
actually made by Rand so that's sort of
the early way that they invoke iron fist
and Colleen wing like they basically
helped her out because remember he's a
billionaire this is a really interesting
line of dialogue where Luke Cage tells
Iron Fist that real power doesn't come
from his actual iron fist real power in
Harlem is all about money and at least
in this place Dany has more money than
anyone else so his greatest source of
power in a lot of these situations is
actually his fortune not just his
mystical abilities they do a good job of
giving misty night her own
self-contained arc
separate from Luke Cage but then sort of
weaving her in with what's going on with
his main storyline and even though we're
looking forward to Heroes for Hire in
future seasons they positioned her is
more of a day-to-day sidekick for Luke
Cage although the series leaves the
characters in a really interesting place
there are a couple big twists I don't
want to get into super spoilers for the
ending they're definitely gonna be
making Luke Cage season 3 but once
you'll see it you'll see how they're
positioning the characters on all the
different defenders series to either
work together or eventually fight each
other so they could potentially make
Luke Cage the enemy of one of the
seasons of the other series they do kind
of feel like they're testing out the
idea of a Heroes for Hire series like
they still want to have Luke Cage season
two and call it a Luke Cage season but
they want to do Heroes for Hire
and they want to do Iron Fist season two
so maybe on a business level they don't
want to mash those two shows together
but I feel like based on what they did
with those characters while they were
doing Heroes for Hire
did you just cannonball into that put
those two together like even if they
don't do 13 episodes of Heroes for Hire
I feel like we needed a little bit more
than what we actually got but like I
said I think the couple of episodes of
that that we got was them sort of
testing the idea proof of concept like
do people hate this do they like this
how do they respond to it
so I feel like most people are down for
it and it definitely helps Luke Cage
with his action problem from the first
season
it took season 1 a little while to ramp
up he spent a lot of time sitting on
pops stoop that was one of the other
really big fixes that they had for
season 2 you open with a really big
action scene so it just lets you know oh
okay yeah we're not gonna be sitting
around the entire season we're actually
gonna be doing a lot of stuff all the
performances were great there were a lot
of jokes that they weaved in with it -
obviously it's meant to be a really
serious series but they did this funny
thing where they turned the metaphor of
coffee for sex during season 1 into this
big running joke across all the episodes
so almost every woman in Harlem that he
runs into makes a reference to coffee do
you want some coffee
he'll just chuckle and say you know haha
no thanks you know Claire's coffee is
just fine so there are a lot of coffee
jokes throughout each of the episodes
free coffee is kind of cool
hey class homebrew is punished all man
don't even go there so just keep your
eyes peeled for all the coffee jokes
what'll happen is is I'll do more Iron
Fist Heroes for Hire spoilery videos
next week I still want to get people a
couple days to watch the series but it
seems like as of me posting this video
most of you have made your way through
at least most of the season but once you
do have a chance to see it just let me
know what you think of it compared to
season one and whether or not you want
them to go full Heroes for Hire in a
future season Comic Con is coming up
they confirmed that they're going to
bring an Iron Fist panel they haven't
said anything about daredevil season 3
but everyone's expecting them to bring
that too because they finished shooting
it a while ago whenever they drop at
Comic Con I will totally do a video for
it no worries
while you wait for everything click here
for that new Spider Man sequel teaser
Tom Holland mister spoiler man he's so
great and click here for more new
Avengers for an ant-man the wasp thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight